Em năm 2018, tại Chủ Sở, UNESCO ở Paris,
kia học lần thứ 2, 2, 2, 2 hội đồng trước hàng UNESCO đã thùng qua sáng kiến của Việt Nam.
Để nghĩa, lên của công bố, thập kỳ của tế về văn hoả vì phát triển bên vấn.
Ý tiên rất đả năm 2019, chá mi bày hàng, in cùng trong bà mi sấu.
Đại sự hối nguyễn thì văn an chừng phải đoàn tuần chủ Việt Nam để tạng UNESCO khẳng định.
Sáng kiến nhận và tuyệt vai chào của văn hoả, trong phát triển bên vấn và ứng phó với các thích thuận cầu.
Điện thoại UNESCO thông qua là bất khởi đau quan trọng, thế hiện nguy tiến và đông khó của Việt Nam trong lính văn hoả của tế,
sáng kiến này của thế hoả chủ chương trình hương văn hoả, nâng tầm đối ngoại đa phương và ngoại xa văn hoả của Việt Nam trong kỳn mới.
Đồng thấy này cũng cho thấy Việt Nam đang này càng chù đậu và có sức anh hưởng lớn hơn,
trong việc định nghiên cứu trình nghĩ sự quan cầu về văn hoả và phát triển.